bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
rugby les plaisirs oies se ressaisit son
fédérale 3 après avoir perdu contre
meaux le 23 octobre
les bleu et jaune n'ont fait qu'une
bouchée de leurs voisins heavy noix ou y
à l'occasion de la 6e journée du
championnat les détails dans cette
édition boxe il est l'un des plus grands
espoirs de la team farruggia il encourt
gallus coulon 26 ans va tenter de
remporter ce vendredi 4 novembre la
finale du tournoi de france pour thomas
citation du club de fontenay sous bois
portrait du boxeur à nant courtois dans
ce magazine
rencontre insolite la hollandaise soreya
ouahdoudi 18 ans l'une des plus grandes
championnes de taekwondo et de karaté au
monde était à 50 ans du bim la sportive
a passé quelques jours en famille chez
son grand-père à montigny-le-bretonneux
pour les vacances nous en avons profité
pour la rencontrer roblin présent sur
les principaux résultats du week-end
on commence donc par du rugby plaisir
m'a pas fait de détail ce week-end dans
le derby noah contre rouille les
plaisirs oies en terrasse et leur
adversaire 39 à 5
un résultat qui leur permet de reprendre
la deuxième place du classement derrière
ris orangis les images ont signé à
nicolas d'ambri les plaisirs oies se
ressaisissent en fédérale 3 après avoir
perdu contre meaux le 23 octobre
les bleu et jaune ont fait une bouchée
de leurs voisins yves binois houille à
l'occasion de la 6e journée du
championnat
le score est sans appel 39 à 5 avec
notamment quatre essais marqués en
première période ce qui a fonctionné en
première mi temps tout au moins c'est
de la patience du collectif un bon
collectif
une bonne application de ce qu'on met en
place je pense qu'on s'est bien retrouvé
devant en première mi temps même si
encore beaucoup de choses à régler
notamment sur la défense où on a un peu
levé le pied en deuxième le temps ce
dimanche les plaisirs ont dû nouvelle
fois faire face à une cascade de blessés
deux joueurs majeurs ont dû déclarer
forfait pour la rencontre dont le
capitaine fonds soit le villan je crois
que c'est le propre de toutes les
équipes et que mais en jouant joue avec
les moyens qu'on a au moment et puis
après la roue tourner j'espère que on
aura
on arrêtera d'avoir une série noire
parce que depuis le début de la saison
on passe pas un match ça me laissait
deux joueurs minimum par dix matches ça
fait peu un beau coup le nombre de
blessés dans l'effectif ne se ressent
pas sur le plan comptable avec cette
victoire les plaisirs oies sont
deuxièmes du classement à 8 points du
premier et seront jce et peuvent
toujours espérer monter cette saison
à la vue des équipes qu'on a rencontrés
jusqu'à maintenant quand je passe le
ghana 3 qui se dégage c'est ris orangis
mots et nous mêmes et certainement après
ou evreux qui viendront viendront nous
nous gratter un peu derrière le plaisir
rugby club se déplacera le 13 novembre
sur le terrain de caen la lanterne rouge
du championnat de fédérale 3
on ouvre à présent une page basket ce
samedi soir trap a remporté son deuxième
match de la saison en nationale 3 les
saint quentinois se sont imposés à
l'extérieur contre leurs voisins évinois
marly le roi la partie a été indécis
jusqu'au dernier moment ils se sont
finalement les trappistes qui se sont
eux qui sont repartis de leur
déplacement avec une victoire 61 58 un
résultat qui leur permet de remonter à
la sixième place du classement à
seulement trois points du leader so on
écoute le trappistes abgué barakaou il
revient sur le début de saison de
l'équipe honnie au micro de nicolas
d'henry
on est encore en rodage
il ya eu des absents et a eu des petits
soucis on va dire des petits pépins
physiques et donc je pense que là on est
sur la bonne pente pente ascendante
ça devrait le faire normalement mais il
nous faut encore quelques quelques
semaines de rodage
on a un effectif de qualité voilà il
qu'on a des grands on a des petits qui
courent on a des shooteurs très adroit
honnêtement on a une équipe homogène et
complète après c'est plus c'est plus du
travail ensemble du vivre ensemble qui
va nous amener des performances hameau
de boxe à présent l'île est l'un des
plus grands espoirs de la team farrugia
il encourt gallus coulon 26 ans va
tenter de remporter ce vendredi 4
novembre la finale du tournoi de france
contre massy attache ou issus du club de
fontenay sous bois
portrait du boxeur élan courtois
remontage d'euros mars min 26 ans 1 m 80
pour 66 kg gay jusqu'où l'on est
aujourd'hui l'un des meilleurs boxeurs
en ile de france dans la catégorie des
poids moyens le trappistes qui
s'entraîne avec la team farruggia ils
ont quoi commencé la boxe à 17 ans après
être passé par le football était plus
solidaire du thé plus individualiste
donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas me tourner vers la boxe
parce que c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours attiré en regardant les vidéos
de rocky mal tyson et c'est donc jeudi
avec un ami en jour on avait aussi une
bulle aussi la mare du football dans
conseil tout dirigé vers la salle
d'elancourt après avoir combattu en
amateur gaydu school on s'élance en
professionnel en 2012 sous les conseils
de son mentor le coach temps guy
farrugia qui l'a pris sous son aile dès
son arrivée au club
c'est un taquet que bien après chaque
mockler à haut niveau et jamais il ya
toujours des choses on n'est pas
d'accord mais donner c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent
aujourd'hui le boxeur affiche un bilan
de 6 victoires 7 défaites et un nul le
stratège participera à la finale du
tournoi de france ce vendredi 4 novembre
à cahors contre ma citation de fontenay
sous bois peut préparer ce combat gaydu
s'entraîne depuis septembre et a mis les
gants avec des sparring partner en
normandie en ile de france et
préparation spa recettes qui le propulse
en favori de la rencontre
c'est pas important des deux favoris je
pense après sûrement aux yeux de
certaines personnes peut-être ne sais
pas mais en tout cas l'adversaire il est
bien là il en finale il n'est pas là par
hasard donc
maintenant on a fait la préparation avec
tanguay qu'il fallait pour être prêt le
jour j
donc maintenant à moi de savoir chez mes
qualités je sais ce que j'ai à faire
pour partir et revenir avec la victoire
s'il ya du school ont remporté son
combat vendredi le trappistes visera un
titre de champion de france dans les
prochains mois avec son club de coeur la
team farruggia tv fil 78 vous propose à
présent une rencontre insolite soraya
ouahdoudi son nom ne vous dit peut-être
rien et pourtant c'est l'une des plus
grande championne de karaté et de
taekwondo au monde
la sportive était à saint quentin en
yvelines a pour passer du temps avec sa
famille à montillot retenu la sportive a
également réalisé à des vidéos pour les
réseaux sociaux patrick jacques de
dixmude à pour les images la hollandaise
soraliens moi je vous dis 18 ans l'une
des plus grandes championnes de
taekwondo de karaté au monde est à saint
quentin en yvelines à sportive a passé
quelques jours en famille chez son
grand-père à montigny le bretonneux pour
les vacances l'expert en art martial en
a profité pour réaliser des vidéos dans
la commune yvelinoise afin de diffuser
sa passion sur les réseaux sociaux
elle est fausse j'ai commencé le karaté
à quatre ans parce que mon père faisait
du karaté il m'a emmené voir un court je
me suis dit waouh c'est vraiment sympa
alors j'ai commencé mon sentiment par
rapport au karaté c'est que quand je
fais ce sport je fais ce que j'aime et
j'adore divertir les gens depuis ses
débuts la hollandaise volante est vu par
les observateurs comme un prodige des
espoirs confirmés par ses performances
sportives sont rien rapportées des
dizaines de trophées majeurs
j'ai gagné le tournoi de hollande
d'angleterre d'allemagne de belgique
d'autriche et le tournoi européen
l'as marck a été opéré le mois dernier
je suis allé au pérou pour les
championnats du monde de taekwondo
j'ai fini troisième
donc je suis la troisième mondiale la
sportive a également participé à
plusieurs émissions de télévision comme
la version hollandaise d'un incroyable
talent en mai dernier
le show est regardé par plusieurs
millions de téléspectateurs j'ai fait du
karaté en freestyle
pour cette émission avec deux autres
filles j'ai fait des chorégraphies avec
un sabre un battant et également un
combat à 18 ans aurait ya espère
désormais participer aux prochains jeux
olympiques et tourné dans des films ou
des publicités on prend maintenant le
large dans cette émission 3 yvelinois
participeront à l'édition 2016 du vendée
globe les versaillais tanguy de lamotte
et éric bellion ainsi que laurent polito
louis burton s'élanceront des sables
d'olonne ce dimanche dans pour ce tour
du monde en solitaire et sans escale en
compagnie de 26 autres skippers jamais
autant divine one avait participé à la
compétition l'écoutent justement
libinois louis burton qui partirent à
bord de son imoca à bureau vallée il
nous parle de son stress à quelques
jours de l'épreuve
c'est vrai que c'est dans la vie d'un
homme a une très grosse échéance qui
approche est un petit peu comme les
artistes avant de monter sur scène on le
traque moi je commence sérieusement à
ressentir le trac là depuis quelques
jours un peu plus de mal à dormir un peu
un peu plus de mal à dormir le matin
aussi donc ça fait des nuits assez
courte
on passe maintenant la tohu briques
agenda
du football pour commencer avec le
championnat de promotion honneur trappe
si qui s'est imposé ce week-end 3-1
contre sevran recevrez une nouvelle fois
ce dimanche à domicile les trappistes
accueilleront à l'occasion de la 6e
journée clichy sur seine les saint
quentinois tenteront de remporter leur
quatrième victoire de la saison pour
remonter au classement pour le moment
les illinois son 12e sur 14 équipes
engagées en cyclisme sur piste le
troisième grand prix de visites
organisées au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les meilleurs
pistards d'île de france seront en selle
pour disputer cette épreuve
ils devraient être plus de 150
concurrents de la catégorie cadets à la
catégorie masters ce le début des
épreuves est programmée à 14h30 la
remise des récompenses est elle prévue à
17h30
plus de 500 personnes sont attendues
autour de la piste pour assister à
l'événement on poursuit à part du rugby
le championnat de promotion honneur le
sky reçoit ce dimanche à 15h sur son
terrain au stade du bout des clots
chilly mazarin à l'occasion de la 6e
journée de la division
le sky rugby doit se reprendre après la
défaite concédée contre triel les
mureaux ce dimanche 16 à 11
les joueurs coachés par thomas payen
veulent renouer avec la victoire dès ce
week-end mais ce sera compliqué contre
les premiers à du classement on termine
à cette rubrique agenda part du basket
en nationale 2 féminine le chesnay
versailles sera sur les parcs et 1 ce
week end le lcv 78 reçoit gymnase bélair
l'équipe du stade français basket ce
samedi à 20 heures
le match est annoncé comme le choc de
cette 6e journée du championnat
les chaînes indiennes occupe
actuellement la troisième place du
classement avec 9 points et un bilan de
quatre victoires et une défaite depuis
le début de la saison le stade français
élu ancré à la 5e place
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve à lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine à 10
il a passé une excellente une excellente
semaine sportive